well the list doesn't just stop at
raiders games these decisions do not
come without controversy let's send it
over to victoria saha with more on how
other indoor venues are handling this
new option
some venues didn't even wait for the
governor's recommendation aeg which owns
the theater right here at resorts world
it's a 5 000 seat theater they said that
by october 1st all staff and guests have
to be fully vaccinated and before then
it's a negative covet test or proof of
vaccination
to be vaccinated or not now depends on
if you want to have a seat and ditch the
mask at a concert or sporting event just
don't like being put in a position to
have to choose ariel ives she spent well
over 16 thousand dollars on season
tickets for raiders games
she now doesn't plan to go as she will
not get the covet vaccine while she's
breastfeeding especially after 2020
where we weren't able to go so now we
kind of feel like we're put between a
rock and a hard place where
we'll probably have to give up our
season tickets this season
wilson cuoc is fully vaccinated but is
still against having to show proof of
vaccination at events i believe it's
individual choice and i would
voice my uh opposition to the venue let
them know why i'm not showing up others
like leah blaisdell and derek leong like
the plan yeah i think it's great because
especially with that many people i think
that's a major stepping stone for las
vegas to kind of set the precedent for
the states in response to the governor's
recommendation caesars entertainment
says at this time we don't have any
changes to share regarding our venue
policy which requires all guests to
remain in their face covering throughout
the performance regardless of
vaccination status
now i did reach out to several other big
venues and i'm still waiting to hear
back for them as for conventions las
vegas conventions and visitors bureau
says sorry the authority
says that they're going to leave it up
to every trade shore organizer to make
their own rules when it comes to proof
of vaccination reporting live victoria
saha 8 news now victoria thanks for that